that's why we need this law our kids
cannot protect themselves they cannot
protect themselves we need to do it
that's our job as adults and everybody
who's remained silent on this issue is
culpable in what is happening to our
kids many members of the media who have
not demonstrated the slightest bit of
skepticism as the medical establishment
has just told us over the years that
it's life-saving care to castrate a
child the majority of the media that
just goes along with that doesn't ask
one skeptical question about it that's
why we need to protect our kids we can
and we must and now Mississippi has and
finally I would only uh say to any other
state that hasn't gotten on board with
affecting kids that it's time to get on
board it's time to do the right thing
it's way past time